[Music]
[Music]
valuetainment giving
[Music]
[Music]
for the rest of his life and he doesn't
pack
tom that podcast is live just so you
know folks that's tom ellsworth and he's
had his coffee this morning
first thing they're gonna hear is you
lit up do you know the scene we're
talking about few good man
i hated that movie really nah yeah did
you really i can't watch tom cruise you
got to be the only person that hated
that movie well you know you got beef
with tom cruise all of a sudden i just
can't watch tom cruise oh my gosh
get into that stop it's like kevin top
gun now you have beef with kevin costner
what do you stand for today
un-american today our guest today is
representative joe walsh
uh he's written a book what is the
book's title by the way it's a very
diplomatic title what is the title can
you tell me the title adam
ceo i know it starts with a word i've
never used i think it's f the f word
right i've never used that word before
in my life
it's tyler it's called uh can you tell
us what the title is calling out trump f
silence f silence
yeah so calling trump out for his
cultish moronic authoritarian con man he
is boom former presidential candidate
2020 yeah he went from voting for trump
to voting for biden and
not supporting trump uh he's been all
over the place he's uh not afraid to uh
uh get in the mix and uh you know round
things up illinois 8th district
congressman also got a podcast called
white flag with joel walsh as well as
same title as your book that you got
there as well okay a few things you've
said i just want to kind of preface the
podcast so they know
uh uh some of your famous quotes okay
this guy uh in the white house stands
for everything i'm against okay and you
were talking about trump john biden
trump is a narcissist okay
obama is a muslim now i said that years
ago and then you had to kind of uh
backtrack a little bit every time trump
opens his mouth he lies yeah i know
desantis deep down inside he's not a
trumper if donald trump runs for
president no republican will challenge
him for nomination the republican party
is occult donald trump is a horrible
person so in other words he you don't
say controversial stuff a lot you're
very
diplomatic and and chill and easy going
so
now that you know who he is joe cruz
have you on the podcast it's an honor to
be here with both you guys yeah it's
great to have you on man and tom yeah
thank you very much now we know tom
knows uh one-liners from uh from
movies and specifically specifically um
a few good men a few good man so
you know if for the audience that
doesn't know maybe you know give a
little bit about your background on you
know what you did you ran yeah why you
supported trump why you turned against
him and why you supported biden and
where you are today so it's a weird
do i need to watch my language not at
all joe you've never watched your
language why start today 60 years old
why not stupid question
it's a weird [ __ ] journey that nobody
else has been on i got elected to
congress i was the big tea party guy i
went there and i raised hell i'm still a
tea party guy um uh i left congress i
got booted out of congress i voted for
trump in 2016 because i knew why people
in this country were pissed off because
both parties suck our politics is broken
government's too [ __ ] big so i
understood why trump got elected right
uh and i voted for him because of that
his people were my people he gets
elected i start to pay attention to him
and i realize he's an utterly corrupt
criminal horrible human being
at the time i'm on the radio when trump
gets elected 200 stations all over the
country i'm on fox news every day and i
begin to speak against trump and when
you do that as a republican back then
you're done so within a couple years i
was done because i just said i couldn't
support this
and then i dedicated myself to doing
everything i can to defeat him and i
voted for a democrat for the first time
in my [ __ ] life in 2020 not because i
like biden he's too old i don't agree
with his policies but to me trump's a
danger so i'm a i'm a politically
homeless
still conservative who just can't stand
where my former political party is right
now do you regret voting for biden
no gosh no no at all yeah you don't
regret voting for budget well yeah it
was an easy vote because and you may
disagree with me patrick but i consider
trump to be an existential threat so if
you're like me and you think that you
got to vote for the only person who can
beat him even if you don't like him so
so let me ask you what was the tipping
point for you what did trump do for you
to say
i don't like this guy boom i'm flipping
i screwed up in 2016 because i didn't
pay attention to him what do you mean
you didn't pay attention i didn't how
could you not pay
the guy
he sucked all the oxygen out of the room
you were paying attention no no no no
you chose not to pay attention i chose
not to okay i i didn't like him as a man
but i really didn't know that much about
him i never watched the apprentice but
again remember i'm a big conservative
voice i'm on the radio all over the
country i can see he's going to win the
republican nomination all my listeners
are supporting him i'm i'm with my
listeners in what we need
but i really didn't take him seriously
and by the way that was a shitty job of
mine i should have once he got elected
and i started to pay attention to him
uh and i realized that he lies every
[ __ ] time he opens his mouth
um
and and it it to me it didn't seem like
he had the interest of the country
uh uh in his in his it didn't care about
the country he only cared about him the
final straw was helsinki the summer of
2018. when donald trump stood in front
of the [ __ ] world and said i'm with
putin my own people can go jump
uh i went on the radio that night and i
said i'm gonna do everything i can to
make sure he's not re-elected and the
minute that happened i began to lose my
radio show so you said you weren't
playing he was the final straw you said
you weren't paying attention to him but
rolling up to the election yeah
certainly you knew after he got the
because right before the election the
turning point for me realizing how
serious it was wasn't that he won the
the um nomination yeah what was the
contrast and it wasn't fox it was all
networks the contrast between the crowds
that hillary was pulling and the crowds
that trump was pulling it was crazy
and at that point my switch flipped in
terms of my
not supporting or not supporting but my
switch flipped on my
my my vagus odds-making
side of my brain they're like wow this
guy could do it i don't think he will i
think there's too much of a machine with
hillary but he could do it because i was
looking at voter enthusiasm what was
your turning point coming up to the
election where you say this might happen
when you say you weren't paying
attention and see and again it's all
relative like i didn't pay a lot of
attention to specifically him obviously
i'm a major political figure at the time
so i'm paying attention to the [ __ ]
race i knew
uh at at the first republican debate
that trump was gonna win the nomination
when donald trump stood up and did his
thing and you had look guys i don't come
from the republican establishment i'm a
tea party hellraiser and you had jeb up
on that stage looking like yesterday's
lunch yeah no inspiration whatsoever
yeah yeah jeb and and marco and all
these guys up on stage sounding like
just [ __ ] politicians and trump gets
up there and says i'm gonna build a
[ __ ] wall i'm keeping these people
out blah blah blah
and he's throwing insults at people
and all the republican establishment
people were telling me that's horrible
uh we cannot nominate this guy but
everybody who called into my radio show
said joe it's about [ __ ] time
i knew then
trump was going to win the nomination i
think i knew a couple months before the
general election that he was going to
beat hillary cause hillary sucked
hillary was the poster child look we
live in a populist moment guys americans
are rightly pissed off at our politics
hillary was the poster child for
establishment politics
i knew he was going to win two minutes
before i felt like he two months before
i felt like he could
yeah that's interesting for okay so uh
uh 2018
when did they start talking about the
russia hoax when did that start that
started right off the bat no 2016
immediately okay right so that was a
disappointment too yeah so so
so so you so that that at all were you
ever like if somebody were to go audit
to see all your recording on the radio
would there ever find a time that you
believe the russia hoax was taking place
did you ever buy into that
no like let's just say we do an audit
right now and it comes back and it says
here's what joe walsh said about russia
gate he believed it he said yeah he had
he collusion we should put him in jail
we should impeach them
would any of those snippets be found of
you saying that no no well i i actually
i i don't know where the question's
coming from because i generally
i believe
and i think it's fact that russia [ __ ]
with our election in 2016 to help get
trump elected i think that's obvious
and after trump won in 2016 and then it
became public like russia did this
trump's first instinct was to get pissed
off about it trump just got [ __ ]
elected and our intelligence people come
out with i mean everybody around trump
knows that russia [ __ ] with that
election to help get trump elected the
only one who couldn't admit stop saying
that stop it it's true stop you can't
say that so showcasing
but i know you can say that but it
doesn't mean it makes it true you can
say that and make a statement
like that to interject there's two
separate things you're talking about did
russia
meddle in the election with bots and
twitter
that is separate it was did trump
collude with russia because in his face
those are two separate things did russia
have bots and twitter and all yes
did trump collude that's a separate
question and that's essentially what
pat's saying he's saying that's what was
marketed but that wasn't true but is pat
acknowledging that russia [ __ ] in the
election
i will acknowledge that u.s has
participated in every election they can
in the world and i would acknowledge
that china russia
and any major empire in america in the
world has involved has been involved in
other elections i would say everybody
does that so what that means doesn't
give your statement a lot of credibility
what i will say is the following was
there ever a time where you tried to get
closer with trump to get a job on his
administration or you wanted to meet
with him or you wanted to have any kind
of a you know hey why don't you come on
my radio show and he turned you down
multiple times or he did an offer job
where he got offended were you ever
offended there was a time yeah yeah
cause remember pat i'm i'm uh
like i'm a conservative i'm not a
republican establishment type your tea
parties michelle bachmann like your tea
party bachmann me yeah i mean
yeah alan west justin amash we were the
guys yes but the problem is uh
do you you guys are like fossils at this
point because but i want to hear his
answer
look when i said here's let me remind
you again i asked were you ever offended
because he didn't give you any job on
his administration or didn't want to get
on your show was there anything behind
closed doors that he didn't keep his
promise to you that offended you to say
if you don't do this i'm going to turn
against you and you did
two things you're clearly thinking of
something so i can't wait to hear it
and and just again i apologize because
i've said a gazillion [ __ ] things and
i've probably forgotten half of what i
said i remember wanting him to succeed i
remember having friends in the
administration and when he first got
elected and sean spicer was just a piece
of [ __ ] and and he sent spicer out there
to lie every [ __ ] day i remember
talking to a few people saying my god
trump needs an honest good tough
spokesperson so i i'll become trump's
spokesperson i forgot who i said that to
but early on in the in the
administration i i said
it would be great to be that for trump
that's the only one i think i can
remember but yeah initially
because i knew why trump got elected i
his people were my people i wanted him
to succeed
yeah but so so then that reveals
something so because but that doesn't
impact at all give me a break joe so
[ __ ] no don't give me a break i've been
pat i've been through [ __ ] hell i'm i
mean and i say whatever by choice though
by choice exactly you chose to do this
it's not like nobody forced you this is
america nobody can force you to no i
chose to do what i did and your choice
was hey i i think you know because what
i think of you i think of uh mooch
and mooch is a friend i like much much
and i have
spent time and we've had them on but
similar situation maybe mooch did get
the job and you didn't get the job but
you got the job and then you know 11
days later and seven days later and
that's trump's challenge you talk about
scaramucci yeah yeah of course he knows
what i'm talking about so you know all
of a sudden it's like hey you're fired i
mean that's a public humiliation when
you do that you know trump could have
handled that in a very different way to
fire a guy that quickly after you hired
him there's responsibility in the person
who hired so if you if you fire somebody
that quickly you didn't do enough due
diligence to hire the person initially
so there's responsibility on both sides
but
you know there are a lot of people on
both
ends of the aisle
on the left and the right a lot of times
when somebody flips on biden or you flip
on obama
or you flip on bush or trump or whoever
behind closed doors there was
conversation to say hey if you back me
up i'm gonna figure out a way to get you
a job wink wink and then they don't and
you're like flipping out saying i can't
believe you didn't do this i'm gonna go
and i'm gonna do this so those are the
types of stories that the public never
knows about we don't know about i'm not
telling you there's credibility behind
my no there's not yeah i mean every by
the way just so you know pat um
everybody in my position who came out
and said i'm against trump
i
they did it for their own reasons maybe
some people did it for a money for a gig
for a job uh i can i don't know why
mooch did what he did
i'm telling you that i came when i came
out five years ago and said i can't
support this
i did it for no other reason than i
believe that that that can be possible
[ __ ] can be possible [ __ ] you
ran two years later for president that
can't be possible you you're you ran
against that's the point so you have
that's the point so so you have to come
out five years ago to go and say i can't
stand this because you're thinking the
republican party is divided and you're
thinking you're going to get decided
no no no that's wrong i never thought it
was wrong i never said and i don't
believe the republican is party is
divided it's never been divided it's
trump's party i've acknowledged that
publicly by the way can i hear myself a
little bit more yeah because i'm an old
man lincoln project so go to lincoln
project
talk talk to the lincoln project people
yeah but they're not me i'm not saying
your lincoln project of course not but
the lincoln project people
are against trump and that was a
community that people some people banked
on they said okay
if i think it wasn't my community well
it the lincoln it's more it's more i've
got nothing to do with your community
than mega no they don't no well hold on
i don't have anything guys this is a big
diverse world a lot of people support
trump for a lot of reasons a lot of
people oppose him for a lot of reasons i
don't do anything with the lincoln
project
and by the way some of those guys have
enriched themselves look at my tax
returns i have not pat let me just get
this out of the [ __ ] way now because
i've been through [ __ ] hell for five
years
by chance i
and no [ __ ] regrets and i would do it
again and look my friend you can
disagree with what i did and everything
i've said but i no regrets i did what i
believed okay but when i did that
i knew i was going to lose everything
and did you i did yes yes
i lost my radio show i lost my
livelihood i lost my source of income
i lost let me continue and then jump on
me i lost any hope of a future in the
republican party
i lost ever being on fox news again
um and i've received death threats on a
weekly basis because of what i did you
don't sound like a dumb guy so i have a
hard time buying that i'm not you you
don't sound like uh you don't let me let
me just give you my position
i'll give it to you i'll tell you
exactly my position and by the way
you're on a podcast where we we talk you
can push back you can call me out no
we're already doing it we're having to
join this yeah i [ __ ] like this yeah
so this is this is this is how i like
this this is why we shut the closer you
can't even run out by the way we've got
security out there you're not gonna
leave this freaking you're like an s m
guy but let me say this to him okay
there is no way i sit there and i listen
to a brain that works as fast as yours
does you're witty you're going
you're not done okay you can let's go so
set that aside so the dumb part's not
aside but
you know maybe the strategy you took
there was no strategy it wasn't the best
strategy i hello yeah i agree amen
brother i concur yeah
financially and every other which way it
was a stupid thing to do
but i did it my friend
adam i don't know why this is hard and
maybe you just don't believe this i did
it because i believed it was the right
thing to do why is that
can't you saying there was no strategy
you just went with your gut
completely okay but you're also saying
that you have no regrets you must have
some regrets joe doubts no regrets
no i mean adam what i'm gonna say yeah i
i
i took a big hit
i i could have i could be back in
congress i could have a show on fox news
i'd i'd be on 500 radio stations around
the country the easy by the way pat and
adam in my position
the easiest [ __ ] thing to do
is to say every day that donald trump
walks on water if all you care about is
clicks ratings getting elected that's
the easiest thing to do
i couldn't do that because i just didn't
believe it
that's all adam
i don't that's all yeah i i think um
sometimes for for all of us everybody
sometimes the masses can confuse you
sometimes the masses make you think
you're wrong and it's very very hard to
stand up against masses
the masses can get up and they can say
let me tell you who this person really
is
and he kind of sitting there saying i
don't know if that guy's that guy let me
tell you this person is after a million
times of saying that you may sit there
and say maybe i'm the dummy maybe that
guy is really a bad person and then you
get recruited into the masses the
hardest thing to do in life is to not
get recruited into the masses it's one
of the hardest things you can do because
you're alone you have to stand alone and
that is not easy to do so during that
time
you are not the only person that did
what they did there's a lot of people
that did what they did that turn against
this guy and then when the durham report
came out they're like oh [ __ ] okay so i
got to spin this and i got to say we
know russia was involved in the election
yeah they've always been able to make
one correction what you just said go for
it
i don't know of anybody else
who came from the hardcore mega tea
party world
high profile guy like me who left that
world justin amash
justin amash bailed in 2017. hold on
justin amash never voted for trump
justin amash never supported trump i uh
i supported trump voted for him and
cheerleaded for him during that i love
justin
justin isn't he a libertarian today yeah
yeah yeah yeah
but finish your point he's making a
point but yeah
he left the republican party but justin
to his credit was a never trumper from
the beginning um all these lincoln
project guys and most of these never
trumpers they were never hardcore mega
tea party trump supporters to begin with
i left that world i don't know of
anybody else who did that that's all
pat what like essentially what joe's
saying
that he's not buying no i don't know if
he's not buying it i think he's just
pushing back and this is this is fun i
think we're all having fun here right
now yes i think you are having fun uh in
in a weird way um no not weird
we need more of this by the way pat my
question to you is joe's saying he went
with what he believed in yeah and
there's a there's a level of respect to
that
but what should he have done
looking back in hindsight if he truly
thinks that
trump is a narcissist con man psychopath
all the words you've used
what should he have done should he have
just like told the company first of all
let's let's qualify these words
narcissists sociopaths psychopath
whatever
bipolar hypomanic take all these words
there has never been a president that
ran for president
that didn't think about himself so much
that they were not a narcissist so let's
set that part aside no one's running to
think i'm going to be the leader of the
free world and you're very i'm just a
regular no no so i would say perhaps in
the later half of the 20th century no
i'm just listen the moment media came
out you're not going to become a
president pat anybody who runs for
congress has narcissism yeah you have to
have it but trump's level of narcissism
is on a whole nother the [ __ ] charge
look i agree with what you're saying but
it's it's not off the charts guys it's
not enough the only difference between
trump and everybody else is
trump can't
hide it others can okay so don't get
twisted like these other guys
nobody else is putting their names
across buildings like trump is bro okay
barack obama
right all the congressmen are all
narcissists of course you need to have a
level a certain level of ego to say i'm
the man for the job i'm telling you
right now the the part that we all have
a hard time is when the masses confuse
us and we bought into something that was
a lie all along what are you talking
about the masses though who's the masses
masses are you like masses every single
mainstream media every day talked about
that he colluded in russia that's the
masses everywhere you went everybody
said that was the case everybody you
ever spoke to that's the case they
started flipping people on his own own
site to start believing maybe there was
an involvement in there everybody so
that is the masses the minority was that
sitting there saying
i don't know man i i think we got to
kind of like you know isn't the system
innocent until proven guilty is it
guilty until proven innocent what is the
system here and then that became the mo
against who everybody kavanaugh him
clarence everybody is guilty until
proven innocent uh that system's not
cool to to approach so yes the master's
not disagreeing with the masses the
masses confused so many voters and
voters sat there and said maybe they're
right maybe they're right look i so when
my parents got a divorce both sides
told me bad things about the other side
okay my mother's family would say your
dad is this your dad is that your dad is
this your dad is that your dad is this
and i'm in the middle i'm like no he's
not
no he's not but they said it every
freaking day
no he's not and then my mom my dad's
family your mom is this your mom is that
your mom is that your mom is my mom i
said no i know this about my mom and i
know this about my dad you ain't gonna
convince me on all the other stuff so i
finally have to say listen i don't
really care about you guys that much i
care about my mom i care about my dad i
don't care about you you're secondary to
me my mom and my my dad matter all of
you guys are secondary if you want to
have any kind of a relationship with me
you better respect my mom you better
respect my dad if you can't do it don't
call me just don't talk to me i don't
need a friendship with you i don't need
a relationship with this family you're
talking i need a relationship with my
parents i don't need a relationship with
you i'm gonna be okay what's the moral
of the story here it's very very hard to
be able to sit there and process issues
from both sides and and still not let
your emotions get caught up i think
joe's emotions got caught up that's all
i'm saying go back to my initial
question if you were joe's consigliere
yeah like if you were joe's biz doc to
you what would you have told him
take a month before you make that kind
of a big decision
take take a lot longer and process it
with a bunch of other people before you
make a statement like that because you
actually have influence it sounds like
it took them two years to make a
decision that's not how this works man
that's not how this thing works because
it did no i i get that all i'm saying is
behind closed doors you have to process
that with people that you respect to say
here's where i'm at okay and you can't
just have all the people behind closed
doors people that 100 agree with no you
you time out and again this is the part
i don't know because i don't know joe
that way all i'm saying is when you jump
like that timeout
it it but again to adam's point pat the
[ __ ] jump didn't happen in the night
when trump got elected in 16 and i'm
supporting him i've got an uneasy
feeling
and it took the course of two years
before i finally said that's it
and so you know my wife my lovely wife
who's listening to us right now
in many ways begged me not to most of it
my advisors begged me not to most of my
political consiglioris begged me not to
every general manager of every [ __ ]
radio station i was on begged me to stop
so people were in you're saying joe
don't go against him don't go against
trump don't do this i deserve the move i
can't but you did it anyway um michelle
bachmann
jim jordan many of my former colleagues
in congress
mark meadows called me begged me to stop
i can't think of anybody pat who advised
me to do what i did
so i was in a room for two years with
people saying come on joe what the [ __ ]
we can ride this out yeah
jim jordan and mark meadows people call
me privately i know trump's a [ __ ]
ass but you know what it we can get
through this we can get by it
hang in there the party's gonna be fine
so i i didn't have people begging me to
do this
but you saw some kind of an opportunity
to do that no no no no stop opportunity
to do that let me and by the way i
respect the hell out of you and i love
your background and i love what you've
accomplished
uh we all have strengths and flaws
i was not born with a [ __ ] money gene
i've never been driven about for uh by
money
much to my wife's chagrin so look i'm a
cause guy
if you look through my life generally
everything i've done it's been cause
driven and i do what i believe is right
no matter where i'm gonna sit
financially you're a social worker at
one point i was a social worker i was a
teacher i mean i
i've i'm just i've never been driven by
money so so okay so go back to the
question when you say i don't regret
voting for biden uh uh uh
so for one reason so if it's the reason
the only reason is i wanted trump to
lose i didn't vote for biden because i
like biden well you said it was an
anti-vote yeah but that's not completely
but that's not a that so so to me the
anti-vote and i we've had this
conversation as well many times
i think the anti-vote is an emotional
vote i think the i i'm being straight up
with you every vote
no not necessarily i think i think most
votes are you're right most votes are
but uh uh
i think the logical vote is more the
four vote the emotional vote is the
anti-vote [ __ ] i think so
great we can debate that and talk about
it i think the logical for example
you you hire somebody in a company and
you bring the guy on board and you sit
there and you say
well let me tell you man i really like
this guy
if i really liked a person i was hiring
i'd hire my niece he's 14 years old i
like her a lot i'd hire my nephew but
i'm hiring somebody to get the job done
okay so when you hire somebody to get
the job done you don't say
oh my gosh i'd love to go get hammered
with this guy and party with this guy
and play dominoes with this guy you sit
there and you say this guy's gonna get
the job done period okay so if you can
make and by the way i've made the
mistake of the other way around i spent
the first 10 years of my career in sales
working with people i only liked
i spent the last 10 years of my business
working with people that i knew could
get the job done not just people that i
liked all the time now if i can like
them and they can get the job done guess
what we got a friendship we got a
relationship and that's lifelong but i
think when you say the only reason i
voted for biden is the against vote i
think that's where the emotion is i
don't think you're alone by the way i
think a lot of people voted the way you
i think you could have voted for trump
or voted against him yeah based on
emotion or based on reason whatever
statistically uh the data shows that
people generally vote for president
uh it tends to be an emotional vote when
you vote for your member of congress or
your mayor your
state rep sure it tends to be more you
know what are you doing about the
potholes but generally when americans
vote for president it's an emotional
vote uh pat you talk about getting the
job done look uh
again i'm a conservative i disagree with
almost everything biden's done
there were things trump did that i liked
policy-wise there were things he did i
didn't like but the job of a president
is to do a lot of things and he did a
lot of things bad he didn't get the job
such as
such as making sure the most important
job of a president is to make sure that
the laws of the united states are
faithfully executed to not be above the
law
donald trump repeatedly acted like he
was above the law every time obama when
obama was president and we didn't pass a
[ __ ] law and obama didn't like it
what would we always criticize obama for
that
the pen the phone trump did the same
[ __ ] thing he couldn't get his wall
passed money for his wall passed through
the appropriate process so just find a
[ __ ] sign a [ __ ] executive order
trump did a number of those they both do
i mean both sides do it but trump did a
lot of that as well
that's a pretty weak argument on what
things he didn't do right what else you
know what he didn't do right he didn't
defend the united states of america
[ __ ] oh my god like oh give me by
the way
you want to get back into policy his
tariffs i think were horrible for
america a horrible for american farmers
to china two no two americans americans
paid for those tips but you're talking
about the chinese territory
but wait a minute okay so so far we have
the following let's kind of look because
what i want to get to we we've we've
identified an isolated couple concerns
here one concern which you just were
straight up about it's like listen it
was an anti-vote phenomenal emotional
vote let's set that aside not emotional
it's an antivirus
emotional yeah
my interpretation
that's my interpretation on the other
side on the logical side i ask about
policies you said
uh the law okay he thought he was above
the law okay everybody does executive uh
orders well you know i'm not done with
them yeah so so number two number two
was uh you said uh he didn't defend
america he didn't defend america and you
say terrorists he didn't defend tariffs
which part of it you know
different issues but for if you want to
actually go deeper i would love to see
you go deeper on those two topics go to
broncos two topics aaa i believe in free
trade and so when we when when trump in
engaged in tariff wars with countries
all over the world um those came back
and bit americans americans paid for
those tariffs american farmers were
devastated by those tariffs
that's just one particularly you that's
that's a that's a statement no no i want
you it's not a state it is a statement
somebody wrote award and here's what you
say in the election yeah
the american people were hurt by those
tariffs american farmers went belly up
because of those tariffs they ended up
paying for those tariffs for which
terrorism and then china and china
specifically also so let me let me ask
you a question so let's look at the
alternative so what do we do so let's
just say we do a deal together okay
i'm the better customer you need me more
than i need you who should make more
money
i don't understand what you're saying
okay in instruction in a business okay
if in a business we're doing business i
don't need your business but you need my
business who should get the better deal
the person who needs the other person i
mean no no no no no no no no let me ask
let me say to one more the one more time
i'm slow i'm not picking i totally get
i'll say it even slower okay so there's
two companies doing business okay
you
desperately need the other company's uh
business
the other company with or without you
they're doing fine okay
who should bow down to whose
policies on what to negotiate with
i have to give the better deal to the
guy i need as long as i don't put myself
out of business there is no question
about it yeah of course perfect so if
that's the case who needed who us or
china you're saying china needed us more
than we needed it's not even a question
on who needed who more
china needed us
u.s didn't need china
u.s helped china
china without u.s would not be anything
close to what it is today so we went
from not telling the history of how much
u.s contributed
towards china's success and now china is
a behemoth and our deals still favor
china more than they favor us and
they're doing whatever the hell they
want to do because politicians keep
letting them get away with everything
that's what we want to do no problem
here's the tariff
these are these are our guidelines what
are you going to do right you're going
to sit there and be like oh it's okay
let's keep doing this oh it's okay we're
going to do now so from a businessman
standpoint i totally understand what he
did and quite frankly none of the
presidents both on the left and the
right knew how to deal with a china and
he was the first person that he could do
it so yeah when you do a decision like
that with tariffs
unfortunately
i said this on the podcast on tuesday
and i want to kind of hear your thoughts
on this on what you're going to say
is the following i don't think
all the policies
that america truly needs today if a
president ran with those policies zero
percent chance they would win
let me say it one more time
if a person ran for office today with
policies that america actually needs
not what the voter will vote for those
are two different things well you got to
explain what those policies first of all
what we need is less entitlement what we
need is yeah we need less entitlement
what we need is uh keep going we need
this military expenditure to be put more
into cyber bio warfare protection than
we need other areas i'm with you what we
need is to give incentives to businesses
to keep creating jobs now getting in
their way what we need is an area of
deregulation that's preventing the small
business owners to agree because a
barrier of entries i can give you 50
different things pat i'd agree with 49
of them but what i'm trying to tell you
is i'm going to keep going with this and
i think he was the first guy that was
able to do that but sometimes policies
you make we were this close of breaking
china
we were this close to breaking iran this
close we were this close to breaking
iran we were this close to breaking
china this close and then what happens
boom someone ate a bat huh someone then
someone had to eat a bat if a legend if
he had another child outside the wuhan
yeah he had if he had another term if he
had another term
china wouldn't would be in a bad shape
today iran would be in a bad shape today
and america would have been the leader
of the world but because he was only a
one-termer guess what china's now the
leader pat you've got all these other
guys that are stepping up let me ask you
a question is there anything trump did
during four years that you didn't like i
uh i think he um so okay so let's talk
about that so it's a very good question
that you're asking and i talk about this
regularly or anything you did that
disappointed you so so so he calls him
out quite regularly but go ahead i don't
wanna put words in your mouth i'll tell
you right now so for example
a lot of people in business and disagree
with what i say i have enemies in
business for many different reasons i'm
not slowing down i'm continuing i'm
growing
so people will say stuff about me and
they'll say let me tell you patrick this
i'm patrick dad and patrick this and
patrick that and i watch i'm like
interesting i know okay call
cool
99 of what people says about me i don't
need to go and defend completely
his biggest flaw
is he has to defend
every accusations of him when you do
that it weakens you it doesn't
strengthen you
so so for example take it look at obama
what obama did obama got a million
accusations what would obama do he would
just go dance dance dance no forget
politicians
forget policies but he knew how to dance
with the criticism trump doesn't know
how to do that now some people may say
but that's why i like him great he's a
new york guy you know for many years we
said a new york politician will never be
a president because america is not ready
for new york president chris christie
we're not ready for some luck there's
too much in your face okay jersey new
york whatever you want to call it right
so for me it was that standpoint that he
picked the fight with literally right
every
body he could have avoided 99 of the
fights and just imposed the enemies
could have been china the enemy could
have been iran the enemy could have been
mainstream media the enemy could have
been those guys not everybody else he
would have gone more done yeah he had
new york brash but he had california
bruisability everybody he's a [ __ ]
[ __ ] yeah um
bottom line is he is
whereas obama came from chicago where
somebody hits you you kind of roll with
it you're saying trump's a [ __ ] i
completely he's a coward
oh he's a bully all bullies are cowards
i don't disagree on the on the bully
side but i don't know i don't know about
the the coward side he's an absolute
coward let me ask you this
did you like the fact that donald trump
lied about the 2020 election
refused to concede
refused to participate in the peaceful
transfer of power
and then led to what happened on january
6. so let me tell you how i'm wired you
got to know how i'm wired okay
when the russia investigation started on
him this is how i'm wired i don't know
if they're right that's dirty i'm
talking 20 20. but i'm going to explain
to you how i'm wired
so when they said he's doing this he's
doing that he's doing this i said
if this is true dude this ain't going to
be a good look and republicans are going
to lose the vote for 20 years this could
be a goldwater type of a thing and could
get very very ugly for the republican
party
okay cool so 2020 election
um argo came out how long ago 30 years
after argo happened which was when
1978-79 when did the movie come out cia
has a basic 30-year rule or whatever the
timeline is they got a 20 or 30-year
rule right
30 years later we really found out what
happened at argo okay so the election
what happened
yeah i think we're really going to find
out what happened in 2020 election in
2015. so do you don't necessarily
believe biden won fair and square no i
don't believe i don't believe either one
of them because i'm not on the inside so
for me to give you a hundred percent
answer
i can't give 100 answers and things i'm
not involved in i can give you 100
answers and things i'm involved in i'm
not in the white house okay yeah so you
don't know if the 2020 election was
legit
do you like the fact that trump says it
was stolen
yes or no i think okay so let me you
ever lost publicly
yes okay how much does it suck it sucks
it sucks okay all right so like you've
been saying the last six years you've
been losing it sucks right whatever
since 2018 four years your life all this
other stuff it sucks it's humiliating
nobody likes it none of us like it i
don't like it you don't like it trump
doesn't like it nobody else but what do
real men do hang on one second hang on
so i'm gonna give you my answer so uh
hillary loses 16 what does she say oh it
was it was russia
patrick you're not being truthful with
your audience i'm going to give you my
answer but you're not that's not true
but that is true no the first thing she
did no it's not the first thing she did
on the view and everywhere else
i love you brother but that's not right
the first you're saying she never said
that
the morning after the 2016 election the
first [ __ ] thing hillary clinton did
was go on national television and
conceived
congratulations
and offered
these are two different questions let me
give you i'll give you the answer on
both of them number one
the moment hillary lost still having fun
the moment hillary lost hillary said
there was the bots that helped trump get
elected you can't deny that did she
concede that night with the phone call
let me tell you no she didn't paul d
podesta was in front of every microphone
and she had not the phone call
she went on national television the
morning after the election brother no
i'll tell you no that's not no in front
of you country oh my gosh you're not
gonna let me finish in this part go
ahead i i'll tell you one part okay so
in regards to russia she said that
constantly for
years now what i didn't like about what
trump did here's what i didn't like
about what trump did
the next president inauguration
whether they cheated or not what do you
do not being there
i don't like that
if if if a country has traditions
traditions are above you you know what i
like about what michael jordan said one
time about lebron james here's what
michael jordan said about lebron james
lebron james made a comment he says i
believe there's one jersey in the nba
that needs to be retired forever the
number 23.
they asked my you're from illinois so
you know the story they asked michael
jordan what do you think about this you
know what he said he says no one man is
bigger than the nba
i think trump thought he's bigger than
america i don't think he is i don't
think anybody so
maybe that's your way of saying
that you're disappointed that trump
didn't put the country's interests
before his own the tradition forget
about the tradition forget about the
jerusalems for a minute pat
put what's best for the country is even
if you got questions about the the
election there was an election biden was
declared the winner i don't like it i'm
[ __ ] pissed off it was stolen from me
but america comes first our democracy
comes first it sucks biden won i'll help
him with the transition i'll show up at
his inauguration so the american people
can see that this thing still kind of
works you're disappointed that trump
didn't do that one million percent thank
you one on one this one
by the way i've been saying this for a
long time i don't think there was a
debate on this yeah one million percent
i i i
i i joe didn't know that he wanted to
hear that yeah
but what i'm saying
i'm living in america
i'm i'm i'm nothing in america there's
two ways i view myself one
i'm one person you're just one person
you're just one but you can't really
make an impact i know for a fact that i
can make an impact but i also think from
the other center bipolar relation i'm
just if i die tomorrow world's going to
continue no steve java was a massive guy
he died we moved on when you and i die
we're going to move on this has been
said a lot of different scriptures a lot
of good books and you can read about it
as much of an important person we think
we're going to move on and the world's
going to move on with us i don't
disagree with that part but go back to
logic policies
policies you still have to make an
argument for the policies you got
trump's policies take trump out
take trump's method of communication out
take trump's bullying style out
take bidens the method of knocking you
know i'm not going to knock you on the
policy side look where america is today
versus when we were under trump i said
it publicly at the time i've said it
every time since i am closer obviously
to trump's policies than i am to biden's
policies i made my decision
that trump's threat to the rule of law
and democracy and i think it played out
during the 20 election to me
was of greater concern than the policy
differences hang on which is why go
ahead tom can we address that because
you're talking about the rule of law so
do you believe that joe biden
legitimately won the election yeah so
we're not going to talk about the fact
that they changed voting laws that they
allowed without approval from state
congressional boards that they allowed
mail-in boating that we had the least
number of attracted votes ever in
american history with the highest amount
of mail-in ballots they eliminated voter
signatures
mark zuckerberg dumped how many hundreds
of million dollars into creating his own
voting laws essentially
all this stuff right so so donald trump
two things could be true at once donald
trump can be incorrect that the voting
machines were hacked et cetera et cetera
while at the same time saying that
the rules and the laws were messed with
because of covet and also so it was not
donald trump who locked down the entire
american population it was not donald
trump who let the summer of love riots
go on and happen it's not donald trump
who accepted ten percent from the big
like all these things are coming out so
[ __ ] like that always happens but you
made a great point
and this is why trump is so [ __ ]
stupid
if donald trump my friend had said what
you said
that oh my god we've got states that
have changed their rules and we're
making it much more liberal to vote by
mail
um oh my gosh
if trump had focused on stuff like that
instead of saying there's it was stolen
voter fraud trump could have made a
credible case so but can two things not
be true at once donald trump can be
pompous and arrogant and
as pat said show it off more than the
other like let's not forget barack obama
is building a 486 million dollar plaza
to himself in chicago he wrote an 800
page autobiography hillary clinton
in 2022 just came out and read her
election speech okay and they spent so
every president is narcissistic but at
the same time
donald trump is not a threat to
democracy the republican party is not a
threat to democracy it's not the
republican party that has a wide open
border with three million immigrants
crossing that's what makes this a cool
country because you and i can disagree
on that um
we were living in a once-in-a-lifetime
pandemic health crisis
so some states made it easier for people
to vote by mail you can have a problem
with that but then have that [ __ ]
discussion and talk about that
um and that's how it should have been
talked about i tend to believe
right in 2020 in the m and i'm
in in the middle of a once-in-a-lifetime
pandemic
states because a lot of older people did
not want to go anywhere in person to
vote states should do whatever they can
to make it easier for people to vote in
a health crisis like that
trump if he had been smart would have
championed that that kind of cause and
by the way guys
if trump had been smart when we were hit
by kovid once covid hit i remember
turning to people i knew saying this
this could be a great opportunity for
trump he can lead the country through
this this is like we're at war against a
virus but he just wasn't capable of
doing that but i also don't believe that
accurate that's accurate florida closed
for two weeks two weeks i was here the
entire time
and florida was literally middle of the
country in terms of death rates so i'm
not talking about that and i'm not
disagreeing with you and if i had been a
governor of a state i would have been
much more like governor desantis in
florida than governor newsom in
california i agree with you on that
that's a separate issue i would not have
locked down [ __ ]
i'm not a
so i'm not a lib i'm not
the debate that we have all the time
that i catch a lot of flak from is
policies versus personality
pat has a very unique
ability to disregard all the bs that
comes from a shitty personality and i do
think that trump is a lot of what you
said
but pat has a unique ability to say yeah
yep
he fights with enemies too much he says
things that are horrible he probably
shouldn't do that he's a bully
but i have the ability to just focus on
policies and that's how you can kind of
grapple through a lot of what
the disgust that people have with donald
trump
it sounds like you have you you have a i
remember when you went on bill maher and
he's like let's go down the list here
buddy right okay judges you agree with
that boom right uh pipelines you agree
with that boom right uh you want to end
obamacare boom all right we agree with
that tax cuts boom and like all the
policies 90 percent you agree with it's
just that you couldn't get through his
disgusting personality
love you adam
it ain't personality but you're right i
probably agreed with 80 percent of what
trump did policy-wise which is pretty
damn good
it's it's it's not just trump's policy
i i'm sorry personality pers excuse me
personality it i i
is he an ass is he a bully is he a
coward i believe all of that [ __ ] i
don't care i do care about that but i
don't
when you act like you're above the law
when you abuse the constitution
when you side with russia over your own
country when you get the head of ukraine
on the phone and say do me a [ __ ]
political figure
a favor and dig up dirt on the guy i'm
probably gonna run against next year
that's an abuse of power that's an abuse
of the powers of your office that's got
nothing to do and pat you can disagree
with me on that stuff that's not
personality stuff to me he's abusing the
powers of his office
that's my objection to trump joe i see
that he acts like he's above he did act
like he's above the law i'm sorry i
thought you paused her at the end i
didn't
roll on you i did um
okay no i did pause
all right well
we're talking when you talk about
policies here my wife's a teacher and we
run into a lot of very liberal
traditional union teachers yes you know
and but are wonderful people dedicated
educators and what's interesting is
we've had this policy discussion and it
goes like this
do you think trump's policies would have
been better
for the country right now and you have
people who made the anti-vote
and in a small room without people
getting upset you know they'll say well
yeah i can kind of agree with that
and i'm like okay so was there an
unintended consequence to your anti-vote
yeah there kind of was oh yeah and okay
so you you so
but if i voted to keep those policies
we didn't know biden was going to do
this we didn't know biden must do that
okay so you voted the anti-vote and you
accepted that there was unknown about
what those policies could look like
versus the known policies that were
going to be there and i take you back to
to
pelosi herself
who was at odds over the health care
bill with obama
and said it's on record just remember
we're going to be here 36 years he's
going to be here up to 8. so there's an
attitude about congress about how long
we're going to be here and how long we
have to deal with any particular
president
and so even
even congress goes that way but i think
this is the way i think about it i think
that that policies would have been
better for america
and yes there's the pompous part i don't
agree with everything that you've said
but there was such unknown on the other
side and i thought the covid and
everything was a dangerous moment and to
go from known policies to unknown
policies america has the unintended
consequence
that it voted for i knew again
just speaking for myself when i made
that vote i said publicly
i i know that i'm going to disagree with
most of what joe biden does i knew that
i it was it was a rat
it was a conscious decision and be the
economic recipient living in the country
under those policies completely by the
way your best friend here said this if
you can look at this hillary clinton
said trump is an illegitimate president
and this is september of 2019. that's
interesting she's a sweetheart
hold on a minute got a lot oh yeah
that's three years after the election
yeah what do you think about that that's
not right off the bat and she's still
saying it three years later what a
what a irresponsible woman to say
something like that you don't like this
kind of stuff right well she shouldn't
be doing this
so if that's irresponsible everything
trump said about biden no what i'm
trying to do no right what i'm trying to
say to you is that is irresponsible okay
so she's everything
she said that three years after the
election that's the point that yeah that
that kind of hurts your argument though
no it doesn't yeah your argument is
trump was saying that a year later six
months later
she's saying that till today trump
trump's still saying that and trump will
say until he dies well why is it why why
why why but why why does her stuff not
get censored but god forbid somebody on
the right says
that it's illegitimate that's not okay
tell me how that's okay but the other
one's not okay there's a difference and
by the way
that's not okay
and i've called that out and i'll
continue to call it out right but you
didn't even know it was three years you
looked at me like but this was until you
realized that this was 19. because what
i knew was this what
when hillary lost yeah
the following morning she conceded let
me finish she conceded in front of the
country congratulated donald trump and
said i'll do everything i can to help
him become a successful president
hillary clinton then showed up at uh
president trump's inauguration
hillary clinton participated in that
transfer of power even though you knew
deep down she probably felt that way but
she was man enough to do it there didn't
have to know woman
there's a lot of controversy these days
surrounding that
things can be true she did those two
things okay but she also was then
immediately on her own tour
she was she was on the view that's where
she kicked it off and she was everything
else was she at the inauguration you're
right she was did she i think take a
perk a man and stand in front of a
microphone the day after yes she did but
she was like that don't downplay that my
friend isn't that really important
if you love this democracy and we are in
a [ __ ] divided country where we're at
each other's throats and every election
is close and man it's hard to lose it
sucks to lose for you to stand up in
front of the country so the country can
know yes i concede i lost he won he won
legitimately this is how our nation
works i will do all i can to help him
become a successful president don't
minimize that i'm not minimizing it both
joe joe
trump didn't have the [ __ ] balls to
do that but she also went to the
inauguration and this is what pat said
pat was very open about this he thinks
that trump should have gone to the
inauguration guys i didn't i didn't say
i gave credit already to that part
that's already been addressed but for
him
three years later she's still saying it
today she's still saying it okay just
everybody knows i think joe would solve
a lot of things for you if you just came
out and said you're a democrat
that would finish everything just come
and say i'm a democracy go be like a joe
manchin no you know what you're right
why don't you just come out and say it
can you just announce it to the world
you're officially a democrat i'd love to
do it but i can't because i'm not i'm
not a democrat but but to your point it
would make my life a lot easier yeah it
it sucks not having a home
but
what's wrong with being an independent
there's nothing wrong with that more and
more people should become independent i
agree i've gone from being a democrat to
an independent but right full-on you
know with your passion and your
intellect but we've gone opposite way
saying lieberman mansion walsh and
talking about seriously i know
so why not because i i think on on
policy
i just do you think i'm being fair with
that people people who are on the edge
of it that say i'm not gonna fly the
whole flag but this is where i'm going
to go
uh
you're completely fair with that
question uh when i when i look at policy
i disagree with democrats on probably 80
percent of policy but they want to get
rid of lieberman they primaried him he
runs as independent and he kicked their
ass when is your birthday what month's
your birthday december december what
twenty-seventh
i know what gift to get you
oh pat what can i
feel you know what i feel like i feel
like this is
frasier december 27th
old school
flip-flop from sportsmart champions and
i'm going to gift it to you tell me what
size it is i'll send you this flip flop
high quality what do you mean you're
switching you're switching you're
flip-flopping man i mean take a stand
maybe but you know what i'll get
ferragamo flip-flops higher quality so
you can appreciate that
i love you man it's very easy that's
nothing it's a friend to call our friend
joe walsh of flip-flops yeah that's very
easy i'm just not just putting it out
there yeah but it's very hard what he
did
it's not easy to say i've been a tea
party conservative my whole life hear me
out hear me out i've been a tea party
conservative my whole life still um okay
well that we can have a whole
conversation whether that even exists
anymore right but
he towed the company line i voted for
trump 2016
and then took him a little longer than
most americans or half of american to
realize yeah this guy really is a piece
of [ __ ]
um and then he shot himself in the foot
the leg and even probably even the
stomach at some point even in the brain
and said i can't do this anymore stuff
but there's nothing wrong with that god
what do you mean i don't know he's got a
glass right now
you're saying that he's just had one too
many five-hour hours of drinks listen to
what you're saying yeah he you're saying
that he should have no trump my guy guys
and just stick with you that's what
you're saying you should have done you
guys were all baptized by mainstream
media and confused
like people have eyes and people have
ears they can hear what people are
saying oh really people have what he
said in hell
people when trump went up there and he
said yes i stand with putin and the next
day he had a reverse course a lot of
people were discussing that let's stay
on that topic stay on that topic right
there
look at the economy today look four
years ago you're not looking at this
situation today
what do you mean oh so you're gonna
blame kovitz yes that's exactly what's
can i talk so wait a minute sure so
you're blaming covet for today's economy
are you also blaming russia are you also
blaming putin are you also now you're
claiming are you also blaming who else
you're blaming
what what
tell us money printing
if it's because of kovit which is your
rhetoric and you gotta you gotta blame
that no problem let's play that card
then why were gas prices 220 in december
of 2020. they were going up before uh by
no swimming but you by the way adam
you're right no
you're going to blame if you're going to
blame biden for what he spent on covid
trump did the same [ __ ] well we know
he's a democrat no become a democrat
no no no because you're because i'll
also blame biden for the [ __ ] that he's
done both can be [ __ ] up
both could be horrible predators do you
take both can be bad you but but that's
that's a that's an emotional statement
which i'm not surprised
both of you guys are part of the
emotional community which i appreciate
this is why there's some people in your
life that can reason and that helps you
out but i think emotions is good yeah
you know i think it's a very
entertaining place to be yes i have a
heart guys but you think but
[Music]
you set the bat about 30 minutes ago you
threw that bat comment in there when we
talked about china okay you also used
air quotes you weren't watching
someone ate a bat so what i'm trying to
tell you is if you play that card okay
and florida shut down for two weeks the
rest of the country florida shut down
longer than two weeks whatever the
timeline was but everybody's coming here
i lived in florida the whole [ __ ]
time we shut down like two months every
no you lived in dallas as well you lived
in texas as well
yeah yeah but but here's the point go
back to it day before covet
mm-hmm go the day before covert february
4th how's america doing
financially you know foreign isis
afghanistan china north korea iran
palestine this israel how's america
doing the day before kovat policy-wise i
showed you already emotional we were at
each other's throats but you're because
there's part of that where people why
each other no no no no why though but
multiple things going on the economy
could be going well for most people yeah
but people could also have there's an
undertone of people hating do you
realize the rhetoric do you realize how
scary it is
for you like a pelosi
to have had control
of congress for god knows how many years
they don't look up at presidents they
look down at presidents
i don't know the same thing
i don't i don't disagree yeah so if
you're going to call out once again are
you going to let me make my point you're
going to keep interrupting just tell
them
so both sides if you
let me finish it's okay you're screaming
i like it so let me tell you where i'm
at here with this
if if we know congress looks down at
presidents they don't look up at
presidents they don't say oh my gosh
he's a president behind the president
behind behind closed doors like this
he's got no influence as much as you
guys think he's got him he's nobody
let's just frickin make him feel good on
his ego he's gonna leave we're gonna
keep controlling the policies and we
keep playing our games and we have the
card so we're invited to the same
parties we'll you know keep using this
to do insider training make our money go
big buy the big houses just let this
guy's ego go we'll go do our own thing
right no problem okay then all of a
sudden a guy shows up
and this guy calls out all your [ __ ]
nonstop
this guy says swamp this guy says all of
this stuff next thing you know
people are asking questions that you
have not been asked for a while
do you think
congressmen should be able to invest
after having insider training i'm sorry
miss pelosi did your husband ever make
any financial decisions after having
insider no we've never done that no boom
that video goes viral congratulations
that was today
but even during that time is when it
started that star that calling out
started during that era it started then
when i was in kind then a guy shows up
and starts asking those questions and
exposes it to america and americans are
sitting there saying
damn if that's true and then they said
hey guys we gotta freaking create a
confusion asap get people protesting get
people riding let's shut down the
economy let's do all this stuff now we
got monkey pox it's horrible oh my gosh
we're gonna dive let's let's use fear
fear fear fear fear the american person
who are emotional
they fell for it and guess what we are
in the state of affairs that we are in
today what
of course they fell for the manipulation
they fell for all the pinning against
each other you fell for it
you said you fell for russia you fell
for russia don't deny it you fell for
russia you believed that was really
going on you fell for it i i i wouldn't
say about the russia thing however but
no no no don't don't go off of it okay
you'll answer this though you fell for
russia why couldn't you fall for russia
did you believe russia was here's the
question i would ask myself you said i
used to always ask myself well why
couldn't trump say one
one bad thing about putin one
uh he's a thug he's a murderer he didn't
say one bad thing he didn't help his
cause at all all he needed to say was
yes
you're gonna deflect no if you're gonna
deflect after the question i'm not
deflecting i'm answering this head-on no
you're not i'm asking you a question yes
the question is did you buy into the
russia gate whatever is going on that
trump's involved with the election
a little bit yeah okay was i all in he's
guilty throw him in jail no you what
stop you did
you ask me to answer the question why
why did you not have any information
i'll go back to my initial statement
trump did not want me you still didn't
ask me so if you're not
saying one time no trump did not say one
bad thing about who's gonna answer he
never he went there in the helsinki and
said i signed your putin and the next
day he said i meant to say i don't side
with poop if you're not i'm sorry that's
a little that's a little aggressive
okay let me let me ask you a question if
you're not going to answer that question
you don't have any corrections just
answer the question no no you did not
okay
i'm going to look you in the face
ask me the question yeah and i'll answer
the question did you emotionally fall
for the fact that russia was happening
without having all the information
i did to a percentage i didn't 100
percent guilty i said there's a high
likelihood something's up here okay
because if he didn't if he wouldn't come
out and say i would never
tr putin did like if you wouldn't
now are you real there's a problem with
like if you're married and i say to the
world you beat your wife up every night
what you should do the next day how
about this yeah if you said hey we
really kind of think that uh your wife's
been cheating on you yeah i'll say well
what you know what proof do you have
well you know we saw her driving around
she checked into a hotel in a motel yeah
she'd been snooping around i'd say
it's not looking good i'd like to see
more evidence but based on it based on
what i'm hearing it's not looking good
and then and then if someone said
uh you see this picture of this
gentleman that your wife has apparently
been cheating on you with uh and you
asked my wife hey what do you think
about this guy and she's like yeah he's
a nice guy and she wouldn't say i would
never hang out with this guy i wouldn't
he's a piece of [ __ ] and she only would
say nice things then i'd be like all
right this is a little weird that the
person that you're cheating on with
you won't even say one bad thing about
this these are two different situations
you use the analogy about the wife by
the way analogy of if somebody said to
you
why do you keep beating your wife and
you've never beat the wife the next day
like what are you talking about like do
you want me to address this issue yes
the more no i want you to address it
head on yeah i want you to say he's a
thug and i do not side with food there
are how hard would those words would
have been okay but he doesn't was that
your problem with him he doesn't believe
that though you you guys are extremely
naive and it's great i i'm surrounded by
naive people fantastic guys you guys are
emotional nice to see you go and stay
there right so so you you want to
applaud for it you applaud trump for not
saying one bad thing about you
if you want me to answer the question so
answer this do you like what trump did
that time in helsinki in the summer of
2018. if you were advising trump before
he stood with putin in front of the
world would you have told trump to say
that can i ask you a question answer
that one first wait a minute for me
answer that one when negotiation happens
what part of the negotiation are you
involved in
i asked you a simple question when
negotiation happens what part of the
negotiation are you going to advise
trump to say that yes or no whatever he
said or he won't answer it
what happened in helsinki
he said or he didn't say
here's what you need to know why didn't
russia invade ukraine during his term
you're avoiding tell me a question why
you guys are avoiding it
you guys have been getting emotional
no no no you are now we can talk about
ukraine that's a good separate issue
when trump stood in helsinki with putin
do you like what trump did this which
which part of the court do you want to
do you want do all my commentary on pull
up the quote
be specific i'll give you my commentary
on it
president putin says it's not russia i
don't see any reason why it would be
russia
president putin says it's not russia i
don't see any reason why it wouldn't be
who's this this is trump
asked if he believed he the sp
question was specific president trump do
you believe your own intelligence
agencies which say russia meddled in the
election or do you believe president
putin who says russia didn't meddle and
these are the same
intelligence agencies that worked
tyler's night overnight to make sure
that he was ousted they had a back-up
plan that comey was against then defend
defend what trump said wait a minute
wait a minute so what did he say you're
upset with the fact that he says
president putin says it's not russia i
don't see any reason why it would be
okay let me stood up let me tell you
what my style would be you ready here's
my style
you ready go ahead unlike being
emotional
you know guys like the two of you
i would say to him behind closed doors
now i got leverage in negotiating with
you you're not behind closed doors my
friend no no i i think you missed the
point you missed the point what i just
said
if i sit there and i'm negotiating with
you if i sit there and i negotiate with
you
and i say this
you don't deliver on my asks you don't
have my i don't have your back it's a
different game
you can't come and say something like
this and then behind closed doors you're
not you're not giving me what i'm asking
you but you lose leverage with me so
what do you what are you supposed to say
here tell me what you're supposed to say
so give me what you would say your
president joe walsh next to putin give
me your words yes russia meddled in the
2016 election you're a knight emotional
president that's why you're not a
president pat okay pat can i oh no let
me that's why you're not a president let
me finish what i would have said because
if you would have said that you could
potentially cause the war now america is
getting get hit by because you don't
know how to answer questions i would
have i would let me that's the problem
yes because i was asked who do i believe
i would have said yes i believe
america's intelligence community russia
did meddle with the it with our election
well you don't know that for a fact okay
hold on yes can i can i don't know that
for a fact let me give you one fact and
then you guys can debate this and this
is not a motion there's no name calling
here
he said quote unquote president putin
says it's not russia i don't see any
reason why it would be quote unquote
what did he do the next day trump let's
talk facts what did trump do the next
day
no
no joke no he went and he said i'm sorry
i misspoke i actually said he was trying
i don't see any reason it wouldn't be
i spoke incorrectly trump came out and
made a statement said i spoke wrongly
fact he went is this the trump trump
responded by tweeting that he had great
confidence
so the next day he 100 percent reversed
we're not going to read the latter half
of that tweet as the world's two largest
nuclear powers we must get along
okay first of all it's a separate
sentence
tyler that has nothing to do with what
he said there that's not a separate
point at all nuclear power they should
get along all the time nobody wants to
take your point but the point is trump
reversed made a mistake he knew he made
a mistake because you know what happened
in my opinion this is my opinion someone
came to him and said hey donald you're
in trouble uh you completely [ __ ] up
yeah on the world stage yeah you're
gonna need to go ahead and uh flip
exactly what you said and pretend people
are stupid and said oh i actually meant
i wouldn't be it's the exact same
situation when he said i'm here with uh
tim apple the ceo of uh of apple and he
and he goes it's actually tim cook he's
like dude no i said to him cook it's
like you said tim apple adam do you
realize how much of a fool you look like
right now i don't because i'm telling
the truth do you do you realize why am i
a fool because i think i told you the
exact story that happened adam
so that's emotions that i would say
reading quotes can i you gonna keep
doing this or what do you want to do
okay
so you're watching wait a minute so you
guys see this you guys having some
excitement right you guys getting around
this is fantastic now you're getting
garage on the dock i don't find this let
me let me tell you so now say that yes
fast forward to today your vote
america's a [ __ ] show nobody gives a
[ __ ] what you're saying
whether there's any credibility to that
or not america is a laughing stock in
the world today because of your vote
congratulations phenomenal job guys
awesome stuff you should be proud of
yourself you should be able to brag so i
understand you emotionally have to
defend your vote no you have to defend
yourself i'm not defending my vote i
have to defend your rules because i
think joe biden's doing it's not the
point
you're you're i think he's [ __ ] the
bed but but it's not but things could be
right at the same time adam trump could
be a liar and siding with russia and joe
biden can be a bad president
two things could be correct same time i
wanna believe and i'm gonna believe this
about you pat that if you had trump's
ear before he went out on that stage
with putin
you would have told him advised him not
to say what he said i think you would
you got you guys are living you guys are
living in a but i want to believe you
would have because you guys live in a uh
a a universe where unicorns fly and the
never-ending story you know
by the way so which is great tell us by
the way adam
you started this whole thing 15 minutes
ago
when you said
um
because you still don't buy this you
said what if joe just did five years ago
what he thought was right
and you asked him what would you have
told joe to do
uh and then you went off on i think you
saw an opportunity and you jumped on and
it was a wrong opportunity i think
that's what it was okay i think a lot of
people did what you did i think they saw
an opportunity and uh oh but they they
said let me let me go that's like you
could also say the same thing to liz
cheney you can also say the same thing
about adam kinzinger there's a how many
people have voted how many republicans
these are guys listen
these are these are guys
again
do not be naive when your entire life
has been playing politics and getting
all the french benefits of being a
lifelong politician and a guy shows up
with no politic experience and whoops
your ass it's public humiliation
liz chaney's ass or adam kinzinger's ass
these are people no no he did that
anthony gonzalez he didn't whiplash
cheney's ass you called the father right
you're supposed to do what what she's
doing liz cheney's supposed to do what
she's doing
what what's your point like you yeah but
let's change it was one of 13. but no no
just go down the list anthony gonzalez
in in indiana yeah
i'm kidzinger they're all gone adam
kenzinger is who who who you tell me who
respects an adam kinzinger today tell me
well that's a problem that's the problem
is that which is why it's equivalent
it's equivalent of an andrew yang yeah
okay he's basically saying yeah i was a
democrat but i can't condone this and i
have respect for that
it's the same thing as a republican
saying i'm a republican i've been coming
on my life but i can't condone this i
have respect for that that you say all
the time the people that call up their
own party is who you have lower adam
five percent is very loud so you have to
and i'm telling you tell eric to lower
five percent is very loud so you have to
understand that is still being
opportunistic
that's fine yeah it is
joe's on opportunity he says let me go
against trump i don't think he's going
to get reelected i think there's an
opening
how did that help him
but that's a bad decision i agree okay
exactly
from a career standpoint yeah he would
be from looking at yourself from the
mirror standpoint there might be a
difference looking yourself in the
mirror today you look like a fool pat
you're looking at yourself in the mirror
today if you look at guys what happened
to the fed rates yesterday what happened
yesterday tell me it was raised by 75
bases where we have right now two and a
quarter base fed rate so so right now 30
you're fixed there's two 30 or fixed
right now is what six and a half welcome
to the bike administration your vote
your vote phenomenal job guys i'm going
how's the house uh how's inflation
how's that
how's inflation doing tell me how
inflation's doing pat i'm gonna give you
guys we're gonna 79.1 percent
you guys want it so now when it's logic
you're silent
emotion you're fired up pat logic oh my
god you know so it's only bite and trump
because trump printed money too you
already i didn't support b i've never
supported bailing out since obama days i
agree i've never supported a bailing out
i'm for right now i tweeted this the
other day
the only way we're gonna get through
this where 20 years from now
everything's going to be all right is
you got to let the too big to fail fail
so check
and this started when when did
quantitative easing start under who oh
wait obama well under george w bush and
then obama
okay do i support quantitative ease you
do not okay do i support what trump did
when he put two trillion dollars and
they said here's what we got to be doing
i've never said send out the only reason
i said that
is one reason
one reason only you can't ask
restaurants
to shut down and not go to work and make
them non-essential
and not bail them out you can't do the
two can't go together make sense yeah
okay so i don't think you should have
shut down restaurants in the first place
i don't think you should have shut down
hey if we're shutting these guys down
what do we need to do so he's being
advised on what do we need to do he's
got to kind of think about it you're
saying trump yeah but yeah but the
carers act had five different parts i
still don't support it i'm telling you i
still don't so you're calling out trump
for what he did just like you're calling
out biden for what he i've been doing
how much i've been doing this for six
years serious question it's a business
question how much of inflation today is
because we printed all that money
how much of that inflation is today yeah
i'm not even saying who printed it it's
just the fact that it was printed forty
percent of all that money that very big
role okay very well two trillion was
printed under trump and three trillion
but one more again so both are guilty no
no again when did the first printing
happen what year did the first printing
happen
2020 what what month
march of 2020 okay so what was gas
prices in december that's different from
what was inflation what was inflation go
to inflation what was inflation in
december 2020 before we printed the
money no inflation was two percent if
not less that's after okay what was
inflation in december of 2020 december
of 2020 because we had already printed
the money yes we had three quarters ago
what was inflation in december of 2020
around 2 1.4 okay what was inflation a
month before ukraine
a month before the uh
february of this five percent seven
point four percent okay so what's your
what's your excuse now let's hear it uh
i'm asking how much he's not making i'm
not talking about gas price what i'm
saying
policies have consequences i agree with
you if you take covet out yes if you
take covet out
you'd be sitting here economy galore if
you say if you take care of it
but kobe was a great opportunity
was a great opportunity for the left
they capitalized off covet in a
phenomenal job and the two democrats
that are saying and that's what any
political party was that's what you said
and by the way coming together that's
true in the united states
look pat i i i enjoy this and i love
chatting with you but brother
again just
be real with me i'm not a democrat you
can call me a son of a [ __ ] and a
dishonest opportunist i'm not you you
said you said you are glad you voted for
biden and you said you're happy you did
yeah so you've had a year and a half to
assess that and i don't and you're still
happy about it don't regret that vote
okay so what do you think what the
situation today pat the situation we're
in today why are we in the situation we
are today no no no stop my friend
exactly just no let's get him off listen
no
listen why are we in the situation we
are today tell me
i asked you a specific question which is
what am i a democrat
based on what you're saying that you
don't regret your vote of course you're
a democrat that makes me a democrat even
though i'm not a democrat because i'm
not because because you supported
policies of a democrat pat if i vote for
a democrat or a republican republicans
independence vote if i claim if i claim
i'm not emotional it's a nice position
if i claim i'm not emotional if i claim
i'm not emotional which you're saying
you're not okay if i claim i'm not what
part of your vote today did independents
vote for biden and twenty what part of
your vote
just doesn't like because you have an
answer my question how much longer is
this guy you have an announcement having
a ball you haven't asked for a question
here no you know i'm sitting five feet
from you about three feet three feet
yeah and i'm telling you to your face
i am not a registered democrat what part
of the policies you voted for are you
happy with today
i'm not happy with let me finish a
thought i want to hear it i policy as
i've said the specific i'm not happy
with the vast majority of policies biden
has done i'm not a democrat i don't
regret my vote plenty of independents
and republicans voted for biden too pat
they're not democrats maybe they don't
regret their vote but they're not
democrats but that's the difference
though no you called me a democrat
that's a different though you you
supported what
but if you validate the point i'll thank
you i love you man and this isn't a
moment if you're validating the points
there's no point
then tell me your policies
what policies you voted for what
policies you voted for pat are you happy
for the vote pat yes i'm not going to
tell you a damn thing
if you continue to call me a democrat
then tell me what no no no no no no no
no you don't support no no then tell me
what policies you don't i'm not then
you're then then i'm a democrat then you
because tell me the policies hey tyler
how much longer tell me the policies
okay joe you can get up and leave i'm
totally fine with that we'll open the
door for you i i i may oh and it's you
do joe you're going to be fine no you're
going to stay there you're good
i'm totally okay with that if you
not emotional yeah it really isn't
so so they give me a logical answer i'm
not a no no but stop for a minute yeah
you said it's not emotional i left the
republican party two and a half years
ago yeah
i did not join the democratic party i am
an independent right now mm-hmm
so do not call me a democrat but tell me
what policies you supported that today
are working of biden's policies i'd have
a hard time picking
i can give you one sure i'm glad biden
got us out of afghanistan i'm glad i'll
give you two i like this simple
infrastructure bill that of the
bipartisan infrastructure bill that
biden signed into law those are two that
i approve the vast majority of things
biden did i don't so you so you support
the way we left afghanistan absolutely i
support us getting out of afghanistan
let's well let's clarify that do you
support us getting out or you support
the way we left i'll answer that i
supported us getting out because that
started under trump and the doha
agreements hey hey my friend
yeah that was a promise of trump's that
i supported and i'm glad biden got it
done and i believe that any how we any
way we would have gotten out of
afghanistan was going to be ugly and
messy and it was but i respect biden for
having the balls for doing it yes
pbd let me ask you a question yeah you
say this all the time this isn't like a
set up punch line who controls america
who controls america
what do you mean okay
as far as voter blocks yeah who controls
america 12 okay exactly yeah that's the
answer i was looking for and where are
these 12 percent typically located
they're all over america but there's a
there's a a specific region
that hillary didn't visit let's say
you're saying non-red non written
blue wall that broke in 2016. right so
we're talking about you're talking about
evolving rust belt yes the rust belt the
and joe's from what state again joe
illinois russ bell okay i'm talking
michigan ohio
certain parts of pennsylvania the
western part of pennsylvania illinois
you know iowa that whole restaurant
about hillary clinton you're talking
about police is always imbalanced and
this goes back to
the point you're making with joe those
same people that voted for george w bush
yeah and 08 yeah i'm sorry in in uh 2000
and 2004 those same people voted for
obama in 08 and 12. and then those same
people
voted for trump in 16 and then those
same people voted for
biden in 20. those people those 12
independents
they control america like i'll give you
an example my grandmother not god bless
her 90 years old she voted for george w
bush she voted for mccain she voted for
obama she voted for trump and then she
voted for biden she's not anything like
you're trying to pin him to be a
democrat those same people i asked you
flip-flop each election and and i'm
that's the why why it's why i said
flip-flop you're right
yeah okay you just validated my point i
just said 20 minutes ago i was i was
enhancing your point but but the point
is that joe's saying is like i can go
back and forth
i can't be labeled a democrat you can't
go back and forth from republican to
democrat to independent whatever he can
go from a republican to an independent
to a democrat back to an independent
back to a party he can do whatever the
hell he wants the difference is what
you're registered as versus who you vote
for what i'm saying to you right
register when you vote
you're voting for policies
what policy do you support no pat you're
you're that's a part of the logical vote
the logical vote
as you know most people are i do that's
why i'm part of this world but i gave
you credit saying to you pat has a
unique ability so to remove emotion and
and focus on logic but most people can't
do that right pat don't speak for
everybody when you vote yeah you vote on
policies respect i think that's what we
got but not everybody i agree and i and
i think more of us
now we're finding common ground guys
look at us i think more of us need to
vote for policy there there you go so
yeah we agree i would i think we need to
i think we need to get less on voting
emotional and allowing the mainstream
media to come confuse a hell of a lot
you're right but it's hard to do
one that's hard to do it's easy i
started that's like
that's like saying guys you need to be
in shape i agree but 70 percent of
america is overweight you know why i
love that that's hard you know why i
love free enterprise you know you could
probably write a book about that you
don't know why i love free enterprise
let me tell you i love free market you
know what's the great thing about free
market
free market will tell you if you're
doing a horrible job very quickly
and and there is no debates
everybody knows you know what's the
thing about politics you can spin all
day long and people don't know because
there's not a way to measure
you can spend all day long and the best
spinners do very well in politics
yesterday who's the press secretary of
obama uh of biden who's the press
secretary
john pierre okay
did you see what she said about
recession we're not in a recession
did you guys try to change the
definition of recession no we are not in
a recession are you not familiar with
the nbra or nrba where in 19th such an
audition
let's focus on that so it's the ultimate
spin zone so for for business people you
can't say you're in a board meeting hey
can you tell me why last quarter you
were down 42 percent that that's not
true we're not down 42 percent let me
tell you what we really are we really
are up 82 no no you're down 42 percent
of your revenues that's not true
but that's exactly what it is so in free
market
there is no room for a spin zone maybe a
month
maybe a quarter
maybe six months you ain't going to get
away with it for long term you're
eventually going to get fired
but in politics spinning is an art and
some have it and some don't have it
there you go so emotion works would you
say that okay so the what's the
technical definition of a recession two
quarter quarters declining of declining
gdp
so in the first quarter of the year from
uh
january to april right first quarter we
were down 1.9 i want to say yeah now the
number just came out today breaking news
uh we're down second quarter gdp one
percent 0.9 to be exact so technically
by definition we are in a recession
right now this is happening this july
first was there some recession and i
said in a video yes in june i said
they're gonna redefine the recession and
i said they're gonna try to get this
thing to not be called a recession until
after midterms you're not lying at all
right okay so tell me the truth
would you say joe that would you say
that we are currently in a recession i i
i'll leave that to the experts it sure
feels like it okay hold on because i'm
not an expert but this is stupid for
biden and his administration to be
wrestling with trying to define it
is just idiotic and wrong
how what what choice do they have when
that when someone in the media says joe
we have now entered a resort what choice
do they have how about lead us out of it
well you don't think they're trying to
do that tom well no they're trying to
well they'd like to there is no treasure
there's nothing to do you don't think
that they are trying to do that
you think they're like we love a
recession what are you saying
of course they're trying hey you don't
think the sales people are trying yeah
but the three that aren't doing well so
just gotta let them go let me ask
somebody questions let me ask a question
from joe joe do you want to be here do
you want to leave no i'm fine i'm sure
yeah if you want to leave let's open the
door so you can get out no no i'm fine
okay because we're going to get into
policy you're going to get into issues
today that we want to get commentary on
last 30 minutes if you can handle it
yeah
i can generally handle okay i want to
make one more point before we get into
that let's do it and i'll push back on
you my friend though i know you meant
well i i am i'm not flip-flopping i i
appreciate the birthday present i'm not
flip-flopping on anything i would be a
flip-flopper
if i renounced everything i believed in
i still believe everything i believed in
i made a conscious decision to oppose
trump not changing what i believed in
so
biden's the first democrat i've ever
voted for in my life
i'm still a proud tea party free-market
conservative who made a decision that
pat you may disagree with but i have not
changed who i am yeah and that's all
that's all i my god can't
can't there be conservatives who oppose
trump and conservatives who support
you made the point adam there's no room
in the party for us adam kinzinger and i
are best friends really adam we got
elected together same state
adam knows the only reason adam didn't
run is because he couldn't win a primary
right liz cheney's going to get her ass
whooped next month by the way did you
know catalina love
yes yeah yes great girl uh right but
she's doing what you need to do to be
successful in this party because it's
which is what which is support trump
support trump that's all and that's if
you want to win a republican primary
that's what you have to do liz cheney's
going to lose adam kinziger has no
future in the party right now i know pat
wants to get the topics but no adam
kinsey it's not that he pushed back on
trump it's that trump is the threat to
democracy trump's going to bring down
the united states trump is everything
that they refuse to see the left is you
can push back on donald trump okay jim
jordan has done it uh kevin mccarthy has
done it you can
uh mitch mcconnell is not like you can
push back on trump it's the threat to
democracies it's the i'm gonna cry
because you guys were so brave on
january 6 with the insurrection it's all
that [ __ ] that it's like no this is
absolutely not look tyler give me one
republican
who has publicly said i opposed donald
trump
and and won a rook and won a republican
primary just that i oppose donald trump
and if he's the nominee in 24 i won't
support him give me one republican who's
won a primary okay saying that so um
give me one democrat that didn't said i
don't support obama what is his name the
former uh
what i'm trying to say is give me in any
you know
sorry there's a lot of democrats who are
saying that about violence yeah
absolutely yeah because they have to
distance themselves from them wait wait
wait we have to talk about what's going
on right there and joe go ahead we can
be honest about this right right now why
do we have to say that aren't we all
just being honest okay then i won't say
anymore um what the [ __ ] come on guys
i thought everybody up here is going to
be honest okay here we go right now and
it's a fact leaks have been coming out
the dnc is pressing
for
you know
soft-handed articles that clearly show
democrats or the the um the voting
public and certain other people do not
feel biden should run again and some of
these articles are a little critical
some of them are very soft-handed right
an independent quinnipiac poll said 64
of democrats in these three states feel
that biden shouldn't run again
why is the dnc doing that they're doing
that because they're trying to clear the
way yeah to have a primary in a
non-confrontational way by saying you're
an idiot you're done we're going up
against you they're trying to let the
primary be a fatacom plea at the end of
all this and with
what's going on probably probably right
i think most most democrats i think
don't want biden to run again mm-hmm
democrats aren't why and why is that
here pat has some knowledge let me read
this story 75
they're having to run against reality
and not spend they're having to run
against the economy cnn polls not a fox
cnn poll this is not a fox poll cnn july
27 which is just a day ago or two days
ago yeah 75 percent of democratic voters
want someone other than biden in 2024.
new poll finds that 75 democratic and
democratic leaning voters want another
one the party to nominate someone other
than president joe biden 2024 a sharp
increase from earlier this year in
january february 51 percent of
democratic and democratic leaning voters
said they wanted someone else it's gone
from 51 to 75 that's a 50 increase by
the way
uh the poll comes as as uh
biden's approval rating remains low and
most americans are disconnected with the
state of the country and the economy
inflation remains high and new report
released tuesday
showed consumer confidence slipped for
the third straight month the poll also
showed a majority of republicans and
republican registered voters say they do
not want former president donald trump
to be their party nominee in 2024
president election 55 say they want
someone other than trump to be the
nominee which is up from 49 so from 49
to 55 that's a six percent increase and
from 51 to 75 percent that's a 24
increase thoughts adam
adam
um well
i'm not shocked about biden at all i
think as someone who voted for biden i
would not vote for him again
that's not being emotional that's being
logical i didn't know you voted for
about yeah i'm not a trump fan i don't
know if you've got that that memo
but um i i compared to trump being a
drunk driver and i just wanted someone
else to drive us home clearly the new
driver that we have is also asleep at
the wheel so
again you could it's not a binary
decision i've said very explicitly i
would love
love love love for whoever the next
president is to somehow get 60 approval
rating when's the last time we had that
in america i'm an american i love
america that's the only country i've
ever lived is the only country i want to
live i would love for americans to get
along i would i hate the fact that we're
at each other's throats i hate the fact
that during the 2020 election
i
friends or people that i dealt with we
couldn't talk to each other because we
voted for different presidents yeah i
don't think that's a good look for
america and i don't think trump is the
answer and i certainly know that biden's
not the answer so whoever it is whether
it's a desantis whether it's a nikki
haley whether it's a freaking mike pence
who whether it's a freaking new sub i
don't care who it is i want to i want
whoever the next president is to have a
60 approval rating now you might say
adam that's never going to happen you're
crazy but call it wishful thinking but
that's what i want for america
joe
i don't think that's probably possible
for a while because look i uh
and pat if you and i sat down over
tequila for me and whatever you drink
old-fashioned okay
you your your vision of america
in my vision of the take one right now
i may have my first tequila of the day
your our vision o'clock already
our visions of america is probably
similar really close i believe in a in a
country of freedom free markets and a
government that generally leaves us
alone yep that's my vision of america i
think we're so divided pat and this was
this was before trump trump didn't cause
this divide he's just an ugly
consequence of the divide
but i think we're going through like a
revolutionary period right now where
most americans no longer agree on this
basic principle of what it means to be
an american so i think we're divided for
a long time i think it's going to get
uglier the democrats are in a lot of
[ __ ] trouble because biden is too old
he's incompetent right now they don't
have there's nobody else waiting the
republicans have their issues it's going
to be tough who would you like to see
run in 2024 i've never if you know but
you have to give an opinion i mean it's
a it's a hypothetical would i like who
would you like to see on the democrat
side and who do you like to see on the
republican side i assume it's not trump
or bud i i go i i'd love to see some
democrat from outside of washington give
me a good competent governor i'd love to
see a republican that's
a free market free limited government
are you saying you want a gavin newsom
versus desantis i don't want to put
words in your mouth but you're saying
you want a governor and then someone
outside of washington who do you want
you know names
i i i i i think knew some even though
again i probably disagree with him most
things i think would be a really
interesting attractive candidate
i think a guy like uh he's in washington
ohio senator sherrod brown
i think the democrats need a [ __ ]
fighter i think
the democrats have become the party of
like elite woke wealthy people i don't
disagree and they need a [ __ ] blue
collar who do you want to see on the
right side now you know since you were a
republican your whole life who would you
vote for in the republicans there's
nobody right now that i would zero
you wouldn't support mike pence you
wouldn't support nikki haley there's no
one on the republican side you would
show the show show
i am my red line yeah
and look at that he's looking i don't
have to say anything you're just
validating mine
he's about to hear it joe you're a
democrat no i don't pass that but you i
want to know what republican
and will not because i publicly said
this
i cannot and will not vote for any
republican who voted for trump in 2020.
i mean come on what yeah any republican
who after four years of that guy
still voted so you're doubling down on
your opinion no that that's but i'm not
saying that's a wrong number but you're
doubling down
so the only republican i'd support is
give me uh a good republican who didn't
vote for trump in 2020 and he's a good
hard conservative i'm gonna ask a
question to see how people are gonna
react if you think from listening to joe
for the last hour and 40 minutes he's a
democrat give it a thumbs up and
subscribe to the channel let's see
what's going to happen people make let's
go
maybe we're starting a new movement and
we're going to hear an announcement here
next couple but when you say anybody
that voted for trump
that's
only my right to get that but who does
that who who who do you have that's
everybody that's bill barr that's my
all these people are going to vote for
trump in 2012 bill barr is not going to
run for president thank god no but
anybody running for president bill you
asked earlier
liz cheney and adam kinzinger voted for
trump in 2020. let's not forget that
they campaigned for trump and voted for
him and 20. they didn't turn on trump
until after january 6.
i did not know that liz uh
campaigned and voted for him so yeah
that's my red line that puts me in a
real tough spot that's probably why i'm
going to be an independent for the rest
of my [ __ ] life unless the crowd
calls you a democrat apparently i'm sick
of these crowds honestly i'm sick of it
one more person
[Laughter]
joe what's wrong with being called a
democrat though i'm not calling you one
but what's wrong no no i have no i i
don't mind that yeah
my problem is when i look a good guy in
the face and say i'm not one yeah you
are i just have a problem with that come
on okay let's have a good discussion
freaking
so getting back to the main point uh on
this uh i i think that the
i've made my point a few minutes ago i
think the dnc is trying to use soft
articles that don't really personally go
heavy heavy heavy
on biden they don't want biden to be the
nominee what is that sound are you
hitting something oh i'm sorry that was
me my foot for the record that was the
democrat joe walters
let's talk next topic fed prepares
another mega size a rate hike raising
risking deeper economic downturn uh fed
policy makers remain laser focused on
bringing inflation under control as high
prices prove persistent even if it
triggers a recession fetch chairman
jerome powell told reporters last month
that failing to restore price stability
would be a bigger mistake than crushing
growth and causing a downturn central
bank policymakers raised the benchmark
interest rates by 75 basis points
in june for the first time since 1994
and signaled that another increase of
that magnitude is possible in july but
100 basis point rate hike uh could be
also on the table now didn't they
announce that they did three quarters of
a point because this is not saying they
did yet
this this may have been yesterday
morning and they did it yesterday
afternoon okay so check check to see if
they may be announced i thought they
already raised it no they did a month
ago and now this is another i know i
thought there was another one yesterday
yeah that's correct
did that go through i thought yes put
news
tyler i think it was the reporters
yesterday july 27th okay so go up a
little bit let's read the article about
that fund's rate is now what two and a
quarter that's correct two and a half
yeah multiplied by three round down a
bit that's usually mortgages
multiple times three
and round down a bit so what's two and a
quarter times three is six point seven
five round down a little bit there's
your third oh it's crazy that just
breaking news from cnn u.s mortgage
rates have now dropped you wouldn't
expect that to happen why right the
30-year fixed mortgage rate falls to 5.3
this is down from 5.54 a week before in
persipine new york for 805 credit
make sure you get the whole thing
it does not say that okay in persipine
in new york this is this kind of fun
facts that tom will drop on all of a
sudden and no one in the world has been
persephone is except like 18 000 people
okay so okay so let me ask you what do
you think's happening over here with
these rates tom because because the
biggest thing i want to ask you thomas
the following
rates go up three quarters of a point
dow blows up yesterday after the
announcement what the hell is going on
i think there's two things going on the
first thing is that the fed only has so
many weapons in its arsenal remember
it's just the fed
and
the solution
for
uh inflation is to make the dollar more
valuable so the price of the dollar
which is interest rates has to go up
it's academic it goes back a bazillion
years it's complicated by money supply
m1 m2 which we've really juiced in the
past five years and so that's there now
there are other things that go into the
market
you know going up because you have a lot
of things in commodity oil oil price and
everything so that's everything from
plastics to fuel so the market yesterday
i i don't think you can say market up
yesterday and fed rate announcement
yesterday worked perfectly correlated
because i think what you're about to see
is you're already seeing in the second
quarter announcements that have been
going on for the past two weeks miss
miss miss miss facebook had had its
first down
quarter uh year-over-year quarter
shopify
18 points down yeah what does that say
about e-commerce purchases exactly so
that's another so that's a broad online
retail we already know retail's really
in trouble americans have stopped buying
predominantly and now we see online
retail with shopify so
i think yesterday the two announcements
were not correlated and i trust what all
the second quarter ceos have been saying
which is i got headwinds and i'm uh i'm
guiding down and interest rates are
going to make it worse
let me say something political uh and
and
because i'm
i learned listening to him
um i think trump is going to announce in
early the mid-september
and i've got a contrarian view of this i
think this is still his party pat
and i think he generally clears the
field
i still don't believe desantis would
challenge him
i think the voters look all republican
insiders [ __ ] the wall street journal
and all these republican consultants who
don't want trump to run and they don't
and most of my former colleagues in
congress privately don't want to run but
[ __ ] all them it's up to the voters and
i think the voters in the republican
party right now are still with trump so
i think when he announces in early
september i think he clears the field
it's going to be interesting who's going
to be the left because you're seeing uh
newsome coming out calling out florida
calling out texas you know calling out
so and he's a very very marketable guy
for the last completely very very
marketable guy
trudeau of america yeah newsome's doing
gavin newsom yeah gavin newsom is doing
three things and i don't think he voted
for trump by the way right i'm willing
to bet that gavin newsom did not want to
make sure you know that yeah remember
i'm willing to bet that you could call
him a democrat to his face and he will
not get upset gavin newsom gavin newsom
is doing three things
number one trey i don't care about being
called a democrat i don't care
i'm not one though stop i just take it
off you know that pat i apologize that's
my fault you've done nothing wrong it's
been all that i'm trying to have a civil
conversation you keep poking a bear go
ahead the tom right if i'm not
interrupted by one more demon cut um
anyway channeling rush limbaugh the um
there's three things that news is doing
so we're talking about this number one
he's trying to clear the deck of
potential primary challengers on the
that side number two he's trying to get
early access to the
dnc funds which is bigger the money i
raise or the dnc fund that's the bigger
bucket always is so you always want to
clear the decks because you get early
access to it and the third thing is he's
been testing
against um individual issues and they
are pulling the piss out of it in
california if you look at the polls and
things coming out of the chronicle
they're pulling he is intentionally
making a national statement against
florida and then they're pulling it to
death to see how
it's doing that's all right but here's
the deal guys and it's all part of him
trying to set the ramps that's all
but it's a machine it is and that's all
correct and newsom's playing it but if
biden doesn't run it's going to be a
wide-open primary because there are a
lot of democrats who want to run even if
biden runs joe it's going to be a
wide-open price i didn't say there's no
primary joe and the fact that they're
still mentioning kamala's name as a
potential candidate in 2024 is a [ __ ]
joke i'm not sure
what do you mean you're not sure i think
if biden comes out next year and says
he's run for re-election
i don't think oh you're going to see
arrows in his back like you've never
seen us i don't know president and
there's are you kidding me it's that's
that's a sitting duck right i think a
man is ready for an 80 year old
president
dnc we've now opened up the
sarcasm or dnc is planning the article
cnc is planting articles with the new
york times it's a fact dnc is planning
these softball articles on polling maybe
biden shouldn't do this because they're
trying to play nice with him
respectfully but lay the groundwork joe
the approval rating the polls everything
you just you there's no way hillary
allows kamala to be the first women
president she's not going to allow that
to happen so biden's going to make it a
couple more years and then they're going
to try to figure out somebody you're
especially the first female president
ever she's undeserving of himself she's
not the person for the job shopify
stocks sings 14 after company says it'll
lay off 10 of its work or cnbc stories
shopify is laying off roughly a thousand
workers
which is around 10 global workforce the
company announced tuesday shares of
shopify dropped fourteen percent in a
memo
uh to staff ceo toby uh lutkey and not
acknowledged he had misguided how long
the pandemic driven ecommerce boom would
last and amid a broader pullback in
online spending shopify would move and
cut uh
number of rolls shop if i had more than
ten thousand employees as of december
31st of 2021
shopify bet that the increasing mix of
online spending over commerce in stores
would permanently leave ahead of uh
by five or even ten years luca lucky
said it's staffed up to meet what is
anticipated would be a sustained shift
to e-commerce more than doubling its
employee base since 2019 said the
company in february obviously it's in
different situation today by the way you
know who bought 50 million of shares on
the shopify yesterday the 50 million
who's the lady that was shorting tesla
who's happy wood she bought for no no no
no no no she wasn't shorting tesla she
was a fan of tesla i thought kathy would
know you're talking about arc strategies
no no i'm i think i'm talking about
catty kathy wood about 50 um
uh uh uh let me pull this up yes
i found a dip yesterday got it so
chunk of coin base after scc probe news
so she's bullish on shopify she is
bullish on shopify but the whole thing
is she's big on
right let's go in here a little bit
what he was saying was very very true
there is an illusion of the shift if you
overread the statistics to e-commerce
because we were locked down so
e-commerce was how we were ordering so
many things and then it's good to be out
again and people going to the grocery
store and things like that not to the
mall but to the grocery store and to
home depot and things like like that so
part of that is a pullback so what he's
saying is i over corrected thinking it
was a permanent correction a permanent
pop we did get growth of e-commerce but
i overreacted say permanent so my next
five moves i have to undo that and i
have to pull back a little bit and oh by
the way the economy is cooling by the
way i think there's a ton that was in
that you know what i'd like to see right
now i haven't looked at it in months i'd
like to see where the stock of zoom is
right now where's zoom stock right now
because that was the hottest stock in
the world tyler's 20 20. they've already
they've already had their correction it
goes back about six months you gotta
okay let's see that but it's a good
question tom break down do a case uh
study on zoom right now take us back six
months here see
go to a year go to a year
you know two years yeah oh wow it's been
going down for a year yeah yeah right
well this is indicative of what the
state of the economy is right now
nobody's relying on zoom anymore 400 to
100. what this is
but this is also pat a ceo in control
because it hasn't
see look at the peak i guarantee it's
2020. yes
where was it in 2019. did you see the
number well below 200.
80 bucks okay and where was it in peak
in uh 2020 559.5 five and where is it
now 100. so this is this is this is a
point this is a telltale sign so in
other words you look at it this way a
lot of speculators made a lot of money
in zoom right here but it's 20
over where it was before pandemic is it
really it does well because in three
verses because now it is a full-on
household name i don't think it was a
household name in 2019. that's what i'm
saying take the spike out yeah the net
value of the company is up 20 percent
over pre-pending by the way could you do
the exact same thing for the s p 500
if you want to talk about the economy as
a whole no that's i don't think it's
going to be the same no no way in the
world
but take a look go to smp500 we're
talking depression error or the doubt
you want to go to the dao
no pick an index you like no no that's
an e because
that's an eft etf
that's pretty impressive
tyler man former goldman sachs advisor
to now helping out on the podcast go to
five years
tyler
completely tyler you're going to come
work for me yeah there you go well what
this shows when the economy the and this
is where you got to give some credit to
our friend joe biden
um
2019 where was the s p
below 3000 yeah right where is it now
and then it went down to
20 to what 2000 now it's at above four
where is it right now 40 21 okay so
according to the stock market other than
that blip in 2020 we're doing better but
by the way zoom's not going to go away
what zoom is showing that zoom stock i'm
glad you brought that up
what that is showing us is
people are going back to work at the
office that's exactly right that's
what's exactly what that's 20 percent
pandemic so that means so then that's
interesting would it be
i'd be curious to know the correlation
between a market being up versus that
if 20 we have 20 percent more people
working from home now than they did five
years ago
i think that's probably a right number
24 is is it a little bit more virtual
than before i think maybe it's like a
five or ten percent hike there's still a
lot of people that are working from home
by the way
okay so last but not least let's pick
the last by the way joe you made it you
got five minutes left baby i don't know
if you know bathroom break
hang in there i'm having fun i need more
coffee and hey since we're talking
numbers real quick we got 3 500 people
watching okay 900 people voted i knew it
eighty percent of them say that you're a
democrat
wow honestly guys
tell him to come here right now
absolutely oh man
his word is gospel with this audience
man that you know honestly sometimes it
pisses me off i can't believe they said
no actually
we love our value
first of all you came you know the
audience
likes it
and respects whether they agree or
disagree if there's one thing our
audience respects is a person that has
the guts to come here talk
and uh hash it out on a podcast because
it's different than when you're on a
fox or cnn or msnbc you got 30 seconds
to give an answer you can actually get
deeper here and we all learn and the
more there's a fight the more the
audience wins and i think the audience
definitely won
today so
podcast
you mind talking to the guys about your
podcast what you talk about on your
podcast i don't know how to find you a
white flag i'll do it quickly because
pat everything you just said is right
which is why i like what you do here and
which is why america needs more of this
we're so [ __ ] siloed we only talk to
people who think like us and and and
believe the things we believe in we
don't want to get smarter we just want
our ideas confirmed so this is great
stuff that you're doing i appreciate it
i have had fun i i needed more to eat
i've had too [ __ ] much coffee um
i uh i've been a very divisive political
figure over the last 10 years so i
launched this podcast called white flag
with joe walsh to try to do something
about that divide every week i sit down
with somebody who doesn't think like me
and we spend an hour and a half
debating talking having a conversation
about an issue
had a guy on two weeks ago who said we
should forgive all student debt
[ __ ] i said a horrible idea but we
had an hour and a half respectful
conversation about that so that's all
i'm trying to do right now you probably
have a hard time finding guests who
agree with you you're going to find
democrats you're going to find
republicans you're going to find them
out like
can you give us some examples
we can't we got one minute we've got to
get out so i know where you're going
so anyways let's put the link below to
his podcast by the way a bunch of people
are saying they respect the hell out of
you for coming on and being on the
podcast and uh i don't want my democrat
even though i'm a dead you're saying it
don't say that you're saying that why
wouldn't you lose
so tonight uh folks a couple of things
tonight adam's doing a podcast with rolo
is having a debate with ruslan
three o'clock eastern right here
christian man debating rollo on the
topics of women dating marriage all the
time you're going to operate today
excited to see what's going to happen
with that and then are we back again
next tuesday for podcasts we're back
again next tuesday next tuesday we're
back again on the podcast okay so guys
have a wonderful weekend we'll do this
again next tuesday take care everybody
bye bye bye bye
you